نتواجد الان في قريه امنتالا بجماعه
انوكال منطقه امزميز ما تزال هنا فرق
الانقاذ تحاول استخراج جثتين ما تزالان
تحت الركام فرق الانقاذ لم تسمح لنا
بالاقتراب تم
وضع حواجز لمنع السكان ومنع الصحافه من
الاقتراب خوفا علينا من انهيارات جبليه
محتمله لان الجبال هنا متصدعه وهناك خطر
انهيار او سقوط قطع كبيره من الاحجار كما
ترون هنا معي
القريه هدمت بالكامل
وما تزال السلطات المغربيه
تحاول ازاله الركاب لانتشال اخر جثتين
مره على هذا الزلزال 6 ايام الزلزال
المدمر الذي اودى بحياته اكثر من
20900 شخص اكثر من 2900 شخص
يمكننا ان نرى منهنا من هذا المرتفع
قريه اخرى اسمها ادوس
سكان قريه امنتالا يقولون ان قريه ادوز
جميع سكانها قضوا نحبهم ليله الجمعه
الماضيه الثامن من سبتمبر ولم ينجوا الا
شخص واحد
يمكننا ان نرى من هنا ايضا الجبال متصدعه
التي انهارت على القرى التي كانت
في سفح الجبل
القريه التي اتواجد بها الان هي قريه
امنتالا القريه جميع سكانها نزحوا الى
مناطق امنه
اسفل الجبال يعيشون في الخيام ويتلقون
مساعدات
قريه التي اتواجد بها الان بجماعه انوكال
تصلها مساعدات وتصلها مساعدات سواء من
مجتمع مدني
او من جهات حكوميه
يمكننا ان نرى هنا
يمكننا ان نرى من هنا كيف ان القريه دمرت
بالكامل
يحاول بعض السكان هنا المجيء وتفقد
منازلهم لمحاوله
العطور على بعض الوثائق المهمه او
الانتشار بعض المستلزمات الاساسيه
الدمار كبير
احد السكان هنا
اخبرني ان القرى هنا كانها دابت كانها
كانت من شمع وتعرضت للذوبان
من هول الدمار الذي تعرضت له المنازل
هناك في اخر الممر توجد سيارات الاسعاف
وتوجد سيارات
فرق الاغاثه والانقاذ
مع جميع المستلزمات بما فيها وعناصر البحث
بما فيها الكلاب التي تحاول
البحث وايجاد مناطق الجثث الموجوده تحت
الركام
انا ساعتين تحت الارض انا والمراه والبنيه
ودري البنيه ماتت لي دابا غير الدري عندي
شويه خرج له راسهم من الناس سميتو
هما اللي نقدوا الدريه هي الاولى ميته
عندها
وبخير وعلى خير جبدوني انا تهرست من ضلاعي
والرجل
والمرض هي اللخرى
من جلاله الملك التفاتها قويه بعينه
الرحمه ويشوف فينا
احنا مقبلين على الشتاء بلادنا معروفه
بالثلج دابا الا جات الثلج
والمواطنين المغاربه الله يجازيهم بخير
راه قومنا
الماكله بالشرب كلشي موجود الخير على
الجهد حجز زوينه في المغرب اسميتها محسنين
وجلاله الملك هاد الزوج هادو هما اللي
كاينين في المغرب الا حسبتي شي واحد اخر
احسن دوار في الجامعه ولا دابا خيار زوار
في الجماعه حيت حنا دابا حنا فلاحه وعندنا
واحد هو اللي سكنا هنايا العين حنا
ما عندناش عندنا العين خارج خرج الكميه في
الصيف في الشتاء دائما حنا عندنا الدفاع
عيشنا بخير وعلى خير عيشنا مثلا
باش نديروها عايشين بخير وعلى خير ولكن
ملي جات هادشي